This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. About eight weeks ago, one of the producers here at 99PI ordered a book. Our office receives a lot of books, but this one, this one was special. Everyone wanted to read it. Okay, so first of all, this book is beautiful. I know, it's only, it wasn't just any book. That's the producer Joe Rosenberg. It was a catalog. Oh my god, it's really good. Only it wasn't just any book. That's the producer Joe Rosenberg. It was a catalog. Oh my god, it's from 1908.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。大约八周前，99PI的一位制片人订购了一本书。我们办公室经常收到各种书籍，但这一本，这一本很特别。每个人都想读它。好吧，首先，这本书很漂亮。我知道，它不仅仅是一本书。那是制片人乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）。它是一本产品目录。天哪，它真的很棒。它不仅仅是一本书。那是制片人乔·罗森伯格。它是一本产品目录。天哪，它是1908年的。
Catalog number 177 of the great price maker. Oh, there's so much stuff. The Sears Enduro book, Male Order catalog, was nearly omnipresent in early 20th century American life. In 1908, when this particular issue came out, one out of every five Americans were already subscribers. So this is kind of like the Amazon warehouse before the Amazon warehouse? Yes. Anyone, anywhere in the country could order this catalog for free. Look through it and then have anything their heart desired delivered directly to their doorstep. Like seriously, anything.
伟大价格制定者的第177号目录。哦，这里面东西太多了。西尔斯（Sears）的《Enduro》书，即邮购目录，在20世纪初的美国生活中几乎无处不在。1908年，当这一期发行时，每五个美国人中就有一个已经是订阅用户了。所以这有点像亚马逊仓库出现之前的亚马逊仓库？是的。全国任何地方的任何人都可以免费订购这份目录。翻阅它，然后把你心仪的任何东西直接送到家门口。我是说真的，任何东西。
Parasolus and pipes. Really fancy looking belt. Lost stretch patterns. The world's best. Lost stretch patterns. Oh, headstones. At its height, the Sears Catalog offered over 100,000 items on 1400 pages. It weighed four pounds. Today, those 1400 pages provide us with a snapshot of American life in the first decade of the 20th century. 1596, our new William's special single, Strap Buggy Harness.
遮阳伞和烟斗。看起来非常时髦的腰带。丢失的拉伸图案。世界上最好的。丢失的拉伸图案。哦，墓碑。在鼎盛时期，西尔斯目录在1400页的篇幅中提供了超过10万种商品。它重达四磅。今天，那1400页为我们提供了20世纪第一个十年美国生活的一个缩影。1596，我们新的威廉姆斯（William's）特制单人，带皮带的马车挽具。
What is it? It's a sheep-shearing machine. The administration products have definitely evolved. The Sears catalog tells the tale of a world, itemized. But starting with this very issue, in 1908, the company that offered America everything began offering what just might be the most audacious and in some ways most necessary item of all. And... Wait, these are houses. In 1996, Sears subscribers would come across a drawing of a house. Two stories, nine rooms, gabled roofs, and a price, $1,700. Wait, $1,700 for...
那是什么？那是一台剪羊毛机。管理产品确实在不断进化。西尔斯目录讲述了一个世界的故事，一个被逐项列出的世界。但从1908年的这一期开始，这家为美国提供一切的公司开始提供可能最令人大胆，在某些方面也是最必要的一件商品。而且……等等，这些是房子。1996年，西尔斯的订阅者会看到一张房子的图纸。两层楼，九个房间，人字形屋顶，价格1700美元。等等，1700美元买……
No, I think the whole... For the house? Seagal? Yeah. From 1908 to 1940, the Sears Modern Home Program offered complete, full-size, male-order houses to the Woodbeam homeowner. What would come to be called kit homes? Sears actually provided an entirely separate catalog
不，我想整个……买房子？西格尔（Seagal）？是的。从1908年到1940年，西尔斯现代住宅计划（Sears Modern Home Program）为木梁房主提供了完整的、全尺寸的邮购房屋。后来被称为“套件房屋”（kit homes）的东西？西尔斯实际上提供了一份完全独立的目录
for these kit homes, featuring dozens of different designs. All you had to do was select your preferred model from the catalog, fill out the provided form, send in the check, and a few weeks later, everything you'd need would arrive in a train car. Its door was secured with a small red wax seal, just like the seal in the back
专门针对这些套件房屋，里面有几十种不同的设计。你所要做的就是从目录中选择你喜欢的型号，填写提供的表格，寄出支票，几周后，你所需要的一切都会装在一节火车车厢里送达。它的门用一个小红蜡封条锁着，就像信件背后的封条一样
of a letter to the king or something. It was to be broken only by you. You throw open the door to this box car and you're looking at 12,000 pieces of framing lumber and 20,000 cedar shakes. That's Rosemary Thornton, an architectural historian and the author of The Houses That Sears Built. She says that that train car also came with every single door, every single door knob, a fold-away ironing board for your kitchen, even the mantle for the fireplace. And then you would begin the process of dutifully loading it either onto your mule and card or your model T.
给国王的信之类的。它只能由你来拆开。你推开这节货车的门，你会看到12000块框架木材和20000块雪松木瓦。那是罗斯玛丽·桑顿（Rosemary Thornton），一位建筑历史学家，也是《西尔斯建造的房子》（The Houses That Sears Built）一书的作者。她说，那节火车车厢里还装有每一扇门、每一个门把手、一个厨房用的折叠熨衣板，甚至还有壁炉的壁炉架。然后你就会开始按部就班地把它装上你的骡车或你的T型车。
The lumber came pre-cut, kind of like a giant Ikea set, along with, in true Ikea style, an instruction booklet. If you provided the foundation, Sears promised that working without a carpenter and only rudimentary skills, you could finish your Sears mail order home in less than 90 days. Although Rosemary says those instructions also came with a warning. Do not accept anyone's advice on how this house should be built, follow this instruction manual and do not deviate. So if the old wise encarpenter comes by and says, I wouldn't build it that way.
木材是预先切割好的，有点像一套巨大的宜家家具，而且，秉承宜家风格，还附带了一本说明书。如果你提供了地基，西尔斯承诺，即使没有木匠，仅凭基础技能，你也能在不到90天内完成你的西尔斯邮购房屋。尽管罗斯玛丽说，这些说明书还附带了一个警告。不要接受任何人关于这房子应该怎么盖的建议，遵循这本说明书，不要偏离。所以，如果那个老木匠走过来对你说，我不会那样盖。
And Sears is warning you upfront, do not listen to that man. Sears would go on to ship out some 75,000 homes across the country. In doing so, they helped replace the idea that each new house needed to be built from scratch with the promise that new homes could be standardized, affordable, and within reach of every family. Long before the advent of housing developments in the modern suburb, it was the Sears kit home that gave Americans their first taste of 20th century domestic life. But it's also a chapter of housing history that was almost lost. Sears was not the first company to offer kid homes, nor even the first
西尔斯会提前警告你，不要听那个人的。西尔斯后来在全国范围内运送了大约75000套房屋。在此过程中，他们帮助取代了“每栋新房都需要从零开始建造”的观念，取而代之的是“新房可以标准化、负担得起，并且每个家庭都能负担得起”的承诺。在现代郊区住房开发出现之前，正是西尔斯的套件房屋让美国人第一次尝到了20世纪家庭生活的滋味。但这也是住房史上几乎被遗忘的一章。西尔斯并不是第一家提供套件房屋的公司，甚至不是第一家
mail order catalog. But it came to dominate mail order because its founder, Richard Sears, was that thing that so many people would claim to be over the course of the 20th century. But very few actually were. He was a marketing genius. He just did so many things and one of the one of my favorites is that Sears knew that most farm households would have both the Montgomery Ward and the Sears Robot catalog in the household. So he purposefully made his catalog just a little bit less wide and a little bit less tall than the Montgomery Ward catalog. Knowing that when the farmhouse wife was tidying things up,
邮购目录公司。但它之所以能主宰邮购业务，是因为它的创始人理查德·西尔斯（Richard Sears）是那种在20世纪有很多人自称是，但实际上很少有人能做到的人。他是一位营销天才。他做了很多事情，我最喜欢的一点是，西尔斯知道大多数农户家里既有蒙哥马利·沃德（Montgomery Ward）的目录，也有西尔斯·罗巴克（Sears Roebuck）的目录。所以他特意把他的目录做得比蒙哥马利·沃德的目录稍微窄一点、矮一点。他知道，当农场主太太在整理东西时，
she would naturally put the Sears Robot catalog on top of the Montgomery Ward catalog. I love that. By 1907, Sears and Robot was selling the then equivalent of $1.3 billion of merchandise to American families every year. And it's around this time that Richard Sears saw a way to sell even more. $1.3 billion of merchandise to American families every year. And it's around this time that Richard Sears saw a way to sell even more. Most American families were still living
她会自然而然地把西尔斯·罗巴克的目录放在蒙哥马利·沃德的目录上面。我喜欢这一点。到1907年，西尔斯·罗巴克每年向美国家庭销售的商品价值相当于现在的13亿美元。就在这个时候，理查德·西尔斯看到了销售更多商品的方法。每年向美国家庭销售价值13亿美元的商品。就在这个时候，理查德·西尔斯看到了销售更多商品的方法。大多数美国家庭仍然生活在
in multi-generational housing. The reigning paradigm of the middle class was the Victorian home with its many little rooms divvying up children, uncles, and grandparents. Sears looked at this idyllic scene of families living in harmony and saw a wasted opportunity. Why should newlyweds move into old homes with old things when they can move into new homes and fill them with new things from Sears?
多代同堂的住房中。中产阶级的主流模式是维多利亚式的住宅，有许多小房间，把孩子、叔叔和祖父母分开。西尔斯看着这幅家庭和谐生活的田园诗般的场景，看到了一个被浪费的机会。为什么新婚夫妇要搬进装满旧东西的旧房子，当他们可以搬进新房子，并用西尔斯的新东西填满它们时？
And thus the Sears modern home program was born. And it was a hit, particularly after the end of World War I. When the influx of returning veterans triggered a need for more housing. And there was literature that said, if you really love this country, if you really want to do right by America, by a house, build a house, and that's when kid homes really took off. Sears cut the lumber for almost all of these homes ready to order in giant mills situated across the country. The largest in Carole Illinois at the confluence of the Mississippi and Ohio rivers, covered nearly 40 acres, and the sheer variety of homes it shipped out was staggering.
于是，西尔斯现代住宅计划诞生了。它非常成功，特别是在第一次世界大战结束后。当归国退伍军人的涌入引发了对更多住房的需求时。当时有文献说，如果你真的爱这个国家，如果你真的想为美国做点好事，那就买一套房子，盖一套房子，这就是套件房屋真正起飞的时候。西尔斯在全国各地的巨大工厂里为几乎所有这些房屋切割好了木材，随时准备发货。最大的工厂位于伊利诺伊州的卡罗（Carro），在密西西比河和俄亥俄河的交汇处，占地近40英亩，它运出的房屋种类之多令人震惊。
That first modern homes catalog had over 40 models to choose from, but Sears would go on to offer 447 different designs. Every house in the catalog had a name, but fitting its architectural aspirations. So if you always dreamed of living in a California mission style home but you couldn't actually move to California, you might consider purchasing Sears Alhambra model. Other styles included the Craftsman style Winona and the Dutch Colonial Martha Washington. They've reached from everything from what I would call a Hunter's cabin, from what I would call a Hunter's Cabin, literally a two-room house for two or three hundred dollars to the Sears Magnolia, which was 2,900 square feet, two full bathrooms upstairs, a half-bathroom downstairs, two full fireplaces, a den, even had servants quarters and a servants' private bath. Sears even offered a six-classroom schoolhouse, complete with an auditorium and library, but mostly it was homes. Big, beautiful, empty homes. Just waiting to be filled with
第一本现代住宅目录有40多种型号可供选择，但西尔斯最终提供了447种不同的设计。目录中的每一栋房子都有一个名字，符合其建筑抱负。所以，如果你一直梦想住在加州教会风格的房子里，但你实际上无法搬到加州，你可能会考虑购买西尔斯的阿罕布拉（Alhambra）型号。其他风格包括工匠风格的威诺纳（Winona）和荷兰殖民地风格的玛莎·华盛顿（Martha Washington）。它们涵盖了从我所说的猎人小屋，字面上就是两三百美元的两室房屋，到西尔斯的木兰（Magnolia）型号，它有2900平方英尺，楼上有两个全卫，楼下一个半卫，两个完整的壁炉，一个书房，甚至还有仆人房和仆人专用浴室。西尔斯甚至提供了一所六间教室的校舍，配有礼堂和图书馆，但主要是住宅。又大又漂亮又空旷的房子。等着被填满
things. In fact, if you look at some of the old floor plans, it'll feature the living room, the dining room, the bedrooms, but then it will say, place for a graph of a phone, spot for a piano, place for two tough to chairs. And so he was kind of showing people how to stuff their houses with stuff from the Sears Robot catalog. And consumers obliged. There are tales of first-time homeowners
东西。事实上，如果你看一些旧的平面图，它会标出客厅、餐厅、卧室，然后它会说，放留声机的地方，放钢琴的地方，放两把舒适椅的地方。所以他是在向人们展示如何用西尔斯·罗巴克目录里的东西来填满他们的房子。消费者也照做了。有一些关于首次购房者的故事
who bought what you might call a turnkey operation from the catalog, the house, the furniture, and the many little things that rested on the furniture, a whole new life, all from Sears. In part because the company used its considerable marketing savvy to make it clear that building your house was going to be easy. With a pre-designed home, you didn't need an architect. And with the pre-cut lumber frame, you didn't need a carpenter either.
他们从目录中购买了你所谓的“交钥匙工程”，房子、家具，以及放在家具上的许多小东西，全新的生活，全部来自西尔斯。部分原因是该公司利用其相当精明的营销手段，明确表示建造你的房子将是轻而易举的事。有了预先设计的房子，你就不需要建筑师了。有了预先切割的木框架，你也不需要木匠了。
You could treat it like any other consumer item. Sears even had this ad in the front of the catalog. It showed two rodesa models, one of Sears' most popular houses being built side by side. One was built from scratch, essentially, using ordinary building materials and uncut stick lumber, the other with pre-cut lumber. In the ad, the house with the stick lumber sits unfinished.
你可以把它当作任何其他消费品来对待。西尔斯甚至在目录的前面有这则广告。它展示了两个罗德萨（Rodeza）型号，西尔斯最受欢迎的房子之一，并排建造。一个是基本上从零开始建造的，使用普通的建筑材料和未切割的木材，另一个是用预先切割的木材。在广告中，用普通木材建造的房子还没盖完。
People are collapsed in the front yard, exhausted. And then the house, where it was built with a pre-cut lumber, they're sitting on the porch with a mint jewel up, you know, having just the time of their life. And so all the many people did hire a contractor to build their Sears home. Many did not.
人们瘫倒在前院，筋疲力尽。而那个用预先切割木材建造的房子，他们正坐在门廊上喝着薄荷朱利酒，你知道，享受着他们一生中最美好的时光。所以，虽然很多人确实雇了承包商来建造他们的西尔斯住宅，但很多人没有。
And I have heard many stories about families receiving their kit home and calling on neighbors to help them come out and start the process of building the house. For many families these were their first homes with things like central heating and insulation. In some neighborhoods a Sears kid home might be the only house on the block with electricity. And in 1911 Sears began offering competitive mortgages to their customers which also helped people in neighborhoods of color get around the practice of redlining. And redlining just meant that the bankers and the mortgage lenders would draw a line around neighborhoods where they would not loan money.
我听过很多关于家庭收到他们的套件房屋，并呼吁邻居帮助他们出来开始建造房子的故事。对于许多家庭来说，这些是他们第一套拥有中央供暖和隔热设施的房子。在一些社区，西尔斯的套件房屋可能是街区里唯一通电的房子。1911年，西尔斯开始向客户提供有竞争力的抵押贷款，这也帮助有色人种社区的人们绕过了“红线”（redlining）的做法。而红线只是意味着银行家和抵押贷款机构会在他们不愿贷款的社区周围画一条线。
So Sears didn't do any of that, and that enabled immigrants, men and women of color, and single women who would otherwise never have a chance of becoming a homeowner to have indoor plumbing for the first time. But then the company discovered that it had made a mistake. One that will probably sound all too familiar. From the beginning, Sears had made sure their mortgage policy was like everything else in their catalog, obtainable. The application form was only half a page long and almost everyone who applied for a mortgage qualified Meaning that the average Sears homeowner was also in debt to Sears in the roaring twenties when interest rates were low in liquidity high
所以西尔斯没有做任何那种事，这使得移民、有色人种男女，以及原本永远没有机会成为房主的单身女性第一次拥有了室内管道。但后来公司发现它犯了一个错误。一个听起来可能太熟悉了的错误。从一开始，西尔斯就确保他们的抵押贷款政策像他们目录中的其他一切一样，是可获得的。申请表只有半页长，几乎每个申请抵押贷款的人都符合条件。这意味着普通的西尔斯房主在二十年代利率低、流动性高的时候也欠着西尔斯的债。
It wasn't a problem But when the Great Depression hit things got ugly fast The company ended up foreclosing on tens of thousands of its very own customers I mean it was an emotional devastation. We all know the Great Depression was horrible for so many reasons, but losing a home that you had built with your own two hands just seems like such a twist of the knife. For Sears, it was a PR disaster. Rosemary remembers talking to someone in 2003 who described how Sears had foreclosed
这不是问题。但当大萧条来袭时，情况迅速恶化。该公司最终取消了成千上万名客户的抵押品赎回权。我的意思是，这是一种情感上的毁灭。我们都知道大萧条在很多方面都很可怕，但失去一栋你亲手建造的房子似乎就像是在伤口上撒盐。对于西尔斯来说，这是一场公关灾难。罗斯玛丽记得在2003年与某人交谈，他描述了西尔斯是如何在1931年取消了
on their grandparents' home in 1931. The very same home, Sears had sold them a decade earlier. And he said, for two generations, our family never patronized Sears ever again. I mean, those are strong feelings to go from 1931 to 2003. After years of declining sales, Sears would finally close its modern homes department in 1940. A few other kit home manufacturers, ones that hadn't sold mortgages, they survived. But the Sears kit home boom was over. Then came World War II, and with it, the next modern housing boom, featuring the rise of the suburbs and the prefab home.
他们祖父母房子的抵押品赎回权。正是西尔斯十年前卖给他们的那栋房子。他说，两代人以来，我们家再也没有光顾过西尔斯。我的意思是，从1931年到2003年，这种感觉非常强烈。在经历了多年的销售下滑后，西尔斯终于在1940年关闭了其现代住宅部门。其他一些没有出售抵押贷款的套件房屋制造商幸存了下来。但西尔斯的套件房屋热潮结束了。接着是第二次世界大战，随之而来的是下一次现代住房热潮，郊区的兴起和预制房屋的出现。
The homes so many of us live in today. Meanwhile, most of the Sears homes, the Alhambra's, the Arguiles, the Magnolias, they ended up being sold to new owners who didn't know what they bought or didn't care to know. Despite the high quality of the materials, over the decades as the company became associated with convenience over and above quality, no one wanted to admit that they lived in a home that came from the Sears catalog. It was embarrassing. So a lot of them ended up being renovated beyond recognition. Many were torn down. Others were simply abandoned. And as for where to find the ones that remain. Unfortunately, after World War II, during a corporate house cleaning, the sales records
我们今天居住的许多房子。与此同时，大多数西尔斯住宅，阿罕布拉、阿吉尔（Arguiles）、木兰，最终都被卖给了不知道他们买了什么，或者不在乎知道的新主人。尽管材料质量很高，但几十年来，随着公司与“便利高于质量”联系在一起，没有人愿意承认他们住在来自西尔斯目录的房子里。这很尴尬。所以很多房子最终被翻新得面目全非。许多被拆毁了。其他的则被简单地遗弃了。至于在哪里找到剩下的那些。不幸的是，第二次世界大战后，在一次企业大扫除中，销售记录
were destroyed. So these records are missing? Records are gone, children. Oh, we don't know. They're not just missing, they're gone. They're gone. They're in somebody's burn pile. All that stuff was disposed of. So the only way to find these houses today
被销毁了。所以这些记录丢失了？记录没了，孩子们。哦，我们不知道。它们不仅仅是丢失，它们没了。它们没了。它们在某人的焚烧堆里。所有这些东西都被处理掉了。所以今天找到这些房子的唯一方法
is literally one by one. A few weeks after I interviewed Rosemary, I went to see some of the last remaining Sears homes outside of Carro, Illinois. Town where Sears largest male had once stood. When I got there, the only sign that there had ever been anything there was the name of an overgrown back road. Sears leading to two tiny houses, two Sears' roadesa models, sitting next to each other. They were the twin roadesa models from that original advertisement,
真的是一个一个地找。在我采访罗斯玛丽几周后，我去看了一些伊利诺伊州卡罗郊外仅存的西尔斯住宅。那个曾经矗立着西尔斯最大工厂的城镇。当我到达那里时，唯一能证明那里曾经有过什么的迹象是一条杂草丛生的后路的名字。西尔斯路（Sears），通向两栋小房子，两栋西尔斯的罗德萨型号，并排坐落着。它们就是那则原始广告中的双胞胎罗德萨型号，
with the two homes being built, one fast, one slow, side by side. Now they were in so-so shape, but somehow they'd outlived the mill that built them here on Sears Robuck Road. I stopped to take a look, and thirty seconds later, a man waved me inside. Go to the roof. They're just noisy. They don't mean they try to scare you off, I think. Guy Parks greeted me wearing an old mechanics jumpsuit. As he settled into an easy chair in the living room, he told me that he'd lived on and off
两栋房子并排建造，一个快，一个慢。现在它们的状态一般，但不知何故，它们在西尔斯·罗巴克路上活得比建造它们的工厂还要久。我停下来看了一眼，三十秒后，一个男人向我招手让我进去。去屋顶。它们只是吵闹。我想它们并不是真的想把你吓跑。盖伊·帕克斯（Guy Parks）穿着一件旧机械师连体服迎接我。当他在客厅的一把安乐椅上坐下时，他告诉我，他从20世纪50年代起就断断续续地
in caros since the 1950s. And that he first laid eyes on this red essay nearly 35 years ago. In the house was derelict. I mean, it was... The roof was leaking, the windows were broke out. It was still safe, but it was old. Guy ran into the owner a little while later, and the owner said to him,
住在卡罗。他第一次看到这栋罗德萨是在近35年前。房子当时被遗弃了。我的意思是，它……屋顶漏水，窗户破了。它仍然很安全，但它很旧。盖伊不久后遇到了房主，房主对他说，
how about I sell you the place, and you fix it up. I said, a hill, I can't buy nothing. oh, he saved it all, I'm my last check. He said, oh, I'll make it where you can buy it. He said, 15, I'll sell to you for 15. I thought he meant 1000. I said, man, I would give that for artificial sap in shape. He said, I'm talking about hundreds. I said, you wait right here.
我把这地方卖给你怎么样，你把它修好。我说，见鬼，我什么也买不起。哦，他把所有的钱都存起来了，我最后一张支票。他说，哦，我会让你买得起的。他说，15，我以15的价格卖给你。我以为他指的是1000。我说，伙计，我会给那个价格买下它。他说，我说的是百。我说，你就在这儿等着。
So Guy went out, came back an hour later with the cash and bought the Rodeza for $1500 on the spot. Eventually he'd buy the Rodeza next to it too. The twin. His son lives there now. And I hate to say this but I'm dumb enough that I spent everything I made for the next five, six years on this place. Trying to make it right. Did you know that it was a sears? Yeah I knew all these were sears homes because the man lived down on the corner he worked for sears. Did he tell you any stories about the mill? Oh yeah but he always told me to bad stuff. Guys neighbor told him that a job at the mill had been hard dangerous work as with a lot of mills in the area,
所以盖伊出去了，一小时后带着现金回来，当场以1500美元买下了罗德萨。最终他也买下了旁边的罗德萨。双胞胎。他的儿子现在住在那儿。我不想这么说，但我很笨，我在接下来的五六年里把我赚的所有钱都花在这个地方了。试图把它修好。你知道它是西尔斯的吗？是的，我知道所有这些都是西尔斯的房子，因为住在拐角处的那个男人曾在西尔斯工作。他给你讲过关于工厂的故事吗？哦，是的，但他总是告诉我坏事。盖伊的邻居告诉他，工厂的工作一直很艰苦、危险，就像该地区的许多工厂一样，
it wasn't uncommon to see employees missing fingers. When the Sears Modern Home Department closed, the workers purchased the plant and switched to making crates for bombers during World War II. After that, they tried making their own kid homes under a new name, but ultimately, they couldn't hold on. The mill closed in 1955. They didn't make very many homes after that.
员工缺手指并不罕见。当西尔斯现代住宅部门关闭时，工人们买下了工厂，并在第二次世界大战期间转为制造轰炸机板条箱。在那之后，他们尝试以一个新的名字制造自己的套件房屋，但最终，他们没能坚持下去。工厂于1955年关闭。在那之后他们没再造多少房子。
I think this one down on the end, the little yellow house, was probably the last one they built. And it was just a little, a little shotgun house. My wife's sister lived there until she died. Even Geys house isn't very serious anymore. He's replaced a lot of the original parts over the years. See, a front door? The only thing in this house is
我想尽头的那栋小黄房子可能是他们建造的最后一栋。那只是一栋小小的、小小的猎枪式住宅。我妻子的妹妹一直住在那儿，直到她去世。甚至盖伊的房子也不再那么西尔斯了。多年来他更换了许多原始部件。看，前门？这房子里唯一的东西是
in this room right here, this original was at front door. The Sears Door. The four series of race rides gutted downtown caro in the 1960s. The town had nearly a hundred other Sears homes. Now, maybe only a third of them are left. Guy watched us rest, or abandoned, or reduced to rubble. In downtown, just keep going down, going down, going down.
就在这个房间里，这个原始的是前门。西尔斯门。20世纪60年代，四次种族骚乱摧毁了卡罗市中心。该镇还有近一百栋其他西尔斯住宅。现在，可能只剩下三分之一了。盖伊看着它们腐烂、被遗弃或沦为瓦砾。在市中心，只是不断地衰落，衰落，衰落。
You can see every month or so there'd be another business gone. Finally there was nothing down there, but derelict buildings has fallen down. And since then all that's gone. It's all gone. Nothing is the same. For a long time, Guy Park's little Rodeça and its twin were just two of a small handful of serious homes that had been located and identified. When Guy bought his house of the 75,000-kit homes that Sears built and shipped, maybe 5% had been properly documented, most sat undiscovered.
你可以看到每个月左右就会有另一家企业消失。最后那里什么都没有了，只有倒塌的废弃建筑。从那以后，一切都消失了。一切都消失了。什么都不一样了。很长一段时间里，盖伊·帕克斯的小罗德萨和它的双胞胎只是被定位和识别出的少数西尔斯住宅中的两栋。当盖伊买下他的房子时，在西尔斯建造和运送的75000套套件房屋中，可能只有5%得到了妥善记录，大多数仍未被发现。
If you lived in a serious house, chances are, you didn't even know it. But a little over 20 years ago, one woman took a big step towards changing that. Although, as she herself would be the first to admit, she didn't really mean to. It's pure serendipity that I ended up in this field. This is Rebecca Hunter, and no, she doesn't live in a seer zone. But she does live in a town on the other end of Illinois, a little west of Chicago, on the Fox River. It's called Elgin.
如果你住在西尔斯的房子里，很有可能，你甚至不知道。但20多年前，一位女性朝着改变这一现状迈出了一大步。虽然，正如她自己首先承认的那样，她并不是真的打算这样做。我最终进入这个领域纯属偶然。这是丽贝卡·亨特（Rebecca Hunter），不，她不住在西尔斯的房子里。但她确实住在伊利诺伊州的另一端，芝加哥以西一点，在福克斯河（Fox River）上。它叫埃尔金（Elgin）。
An unlike caro, Elgin was not known for seer's homes. When Rebecca first got there in the mid 90s, almost no one there, herself included, knew what a seerars house was. Then my partner died in 1995 and I was doing everything because it helped. And that's how Rebecca ended up at the local library, where she happened upon a book about Sears Homes which contained old catalog images of the various models, which would mean nothing, except that one bitterly cold day in February 1997. That book happened to be lying on the dining room table. And I picked it up and I said, oh, hi, I wonder if I could walk around my neighborhood and find one of these houses.
与卡罗不同，埃尔金并不以西尔斯的房子而闻名。当丽贝卡在90年代中期第一次到达那里时，那里几乎没有人，包括她自己，知道什么是西尔斯的房子。然后我的伴侣在1995年去世了，我做了所有的事情，因为这有帮助。这就是丽贝卡最终来到当地图书馆的原因，在那里她偶然发现了一本关于西尔斯住宅的书，其中包含了各种型号的旧目录图片，这本来没什么意义，除了在1997年2月一个寒冷刺骨的日子里。那本书恰好放在餐桌上。我把它拿起来说，哦，嗨，我想知道我是否可以在我的社区走走，找到其中一栋房子。
That would be really funny, and so I picked up the book and I said about walking in my neighborhood. How many were you realistically expecting to find? I wasn't expecting to find any. It was really kind of fun. You know, I had a goal. I had a mission and I forgot about the cold. And then after, oh, I don't know, 10, 15 minutes. I was walking down Plum Street and I saw this house and I instantly knew it was a Sears. Right there, after almost zero effort, boom, a series house. Reca looks the house, looks the book, looks the house, looks the book, and it's a match.
那会很有趣，所以我拿起书，开始在我的社区走动。你实际上期望找到多少？我没指望找到任何一栋。这真的很有趣。你知道，我有一个目标。我有一个使命，我忘记了寒冷。然后，哦，我不知道，10、15分钟后。我沿着李子街（Plum Street）走，我看到了这栋房子，我立刻知道它是西尔斯的。就在那里，几乎没费什么力气，砰，一栋西尔斯的房子。丽贝卡看着房子，看着书，看着房子，看着书，这是一个匹配。
Craftsman style, tapered porch columns, the Avalon model. Then I said, huh, I wonder if I could walk around my neighborhood and find another one. And so I did. On walk after walk, Rebecca kept finding Sears Monos. The Mitchell, the Crescent, the Valonia, then there was the Betsy Ross, the Osborne and the Elhambera. In fact there's one street that has a sunlight model on one side of the street in the opposite is the starlight. So you have a sunlight and a starlight
工匠风格，锥形门廊柱，阿瓦隆（Avalon）型号。然后我说，嗯，我想知道我是否可以在我的社区走走，再找一栋。所以我做了。在一次又一次的散步中，丽贝卡不断发现西尔斯的型号。米切尔（Mitchell）、新月（Crescent）、瓦洛尼亚（Valonia），然后是贝齐·罗斯（Betsy Ross）、奥斯本（Osborne）和阿罕布拉。事实上，有一条街的一侧有一个阳光（Sunlight）型号，对面是星光（Starlight）。所以你有一个阳光和一个星光
right across the street from each other. But Rebecca wanted to confirm that these were sears homes. So she sent a mailer out, asking each resident to go and inspect the basement. When they did, most discovered beams bearing a special stamp with a part number from sears. Others found shipping labels from Sears on the back of attic baseboards. Still others managed to find their home's original Sears blueprints,
就在街对面。但丽贝卡想确认这些确实是西尔斯的房子。所以她寄出了一份邮件，要求每位居民去检查地下室。当他们这样做时，大多数人发现了带有西尔斯零件编号的特殊印章的横梁。其他人发现了阁楼踢脚板背后的西尔斯装运标签。还有一些人设法找到了他们房子最初的西尔斯蓝图，
and Rebecca's not even done. There are still more houses waiting to be investigated. What is the total number of houses in Elgin and Bupi? At the moment, I think we are at 237 Sears houses and about 100 from other companies. What's more, most of the homes are back-of-found, looked like they were straight out of the catalog. They'd barely been altered since the 1920s. That's why she was able to find so many, because the homes could still be recognized. And there was a specific reason why. When the Elgin Watch Factory, which had employed a quarter of the town closed in 1964,
丽贝卡甚至还没做完。还有更多的房子等着被调查。埃尔金和布皮（Bupi）的房子总数是多少？目前，我想我们有237栋西尔斯住宅和大约100栋来自其他公司的房子。更重要的是，大多数被发现的房子看起来就像直接从目录里出来的一样。自20世纪20年代以来，它们几乎没有被改变过。这就是为什么她能找到这么多，因为这些房子仍然可以被识别出来。而且有一个具体的原因。当埃尔金手表厂（Elgin Watch Factory），曾经雇佣了该镇四分之一的人口，在1964年关闭时，
Elgin entered a localized recession, sparing it from the renovation craze of the 60s and 70s. Instead, Elgin Sears' home simply sat there through the decades untouched. Does anyone ever point out the fact that the closing of the Watch Factory froze the houses in time? Oh yeah, we talk about that. We love it. Does anyone ever point out the fact that the closing of the watch factory froze the houses in time? Oh, yeah. We talk about that. We love it. We love it.
埃尔金进入了局部衰退，使其免于60年代和70年代的翻新热潮。相反，埃尔金的西尔斯住宅只是在几十年里保持原样。有没有人指出手表厂的关闭让这些房子在时间中冻结的事实？哦，是的，我们谈论过那个。我们喜欢它。有没有人指出手表厂的关闭让这些房子在时间中冻结的事实？哦，是的。我们谈论过那个。我们喜欢它。我们喜欢它。
Rebecca's study of the Elgin Homes, along with the work of other researchers like Rose Thornton, our architectural historian, would help to launch what has become a Sears house hunting movement. People whose chief passion in life is to scour the land, trying to find as many kid homes as possible, including Rose. Some people do crossword puzzles, and some people do jigsaw puzzles. I guess I look for Sears Homes. Well, actually, you may in Rose and Dale and Wendy and Andrew and Nigel and Cindy
丽贝卡对埃尔金住宅的研究，以及像罗斯·桑顿（Rose Thornton）这样的其他研究人员的工作，帮助发起了后来成为西尔斯寻房运动的活动。人们生活中主要的激情就是搜寻这片土地，试图找到尽可能多的套件房屋，包括罗斯。有些人做填字游戏，有些人做拼图游戏。我想我是在寻找西尔斯的房子。好吧，实际上，你可能在罗斯、戴尔（Dale）、温迪（Wendy）、安德鲁（Andrew）、奈杰尔（Nigel）和辛迪（Cindy）
look for Sears Homes. Those names form part of an elite core of the Sears House Hunters, and 18, if you will. And like any proper 18, each member has their specialty. Rosemary Hunts for the Rare Sears Magnolia, the three-story colonial mansion. So far, she says, they found ten. Dale Wolke specializes in kid homes built by Sears biggest competitor, the Aladdin company. And Andrew Mutch is the numbers guy. He's currently working with about half a dozen people on a database that would list every single Sears. Meanwhile Nigel Tate at 19 is the youngest member of their team. He's found over 1,000
寻找西尔斯的房子。这些名字构成了西尔斯寻房者精英核心的一部分，如果你愿意的话，是18人。像任何合适的18人团队一样，每个成员都有他们的专长。罗斯玛丽搜寻稀有的西尔斯木兰，那栋三层殖民地豪宅。到目前为止，她说，他们找到了十栋。戴尔·沃尔克（Dale Wolke）专门研究西尔斯最大的竞争对手阿拉丁公司（Aladdin company）建造的套件房屋。而安德鲁·马奇（Andrew Mutch）是数字专家。他目前正与大约六个人合作建立一个数据库，列出每一栋西尔斯住宅。与此同时，19岁的奈杰尔·泰特（Nigel Tate）是他们团队中最年轻的成员。他找到了超过1000栋
kid homes without even leaving his desk. He uses Google Street View. But mostly they hunt for houses the old fashioned way. Chasing down clues and patrolling the mean streets of America in a car together. And Andrew's up in front and he's got his computer and he's writing down addresses. And Dale is striving and Wendy and I are in the backseat, each with a camera. And everybody's looking out the window and somebody says, hey, what's that over there on the right? Although, let's face it, they're not exactly bounty owners. And so I'm getting out and I'm taking pictures and this very large, angry man bursts out
套件房屋，甚至没有离开他的办公桌。他使用谷歌街景（Google Street View）。但大多数时候，他们以老式的方式寻找房子。追寻线索，在车里一起巡逻美国的街道。安德鲁在前面，他有他的电脑，他在写下地址。戴尔在开车，温迪和我在后座，每个人都拿着相机。每个人都在看窗外，有人说，嘿，右边那个是什么？虽然，让我们面对现实吧，他们并不完全是赏金猎人。所以我下车拍照，一个非常高大、愤怒的男人冲了出来
the front door, he has a baseball bat in his hand. If we get in the car and we take off. The occasional misstep aside, Rosenwebekah think that they and other house hunters have helped identify nearly 50,000 kid homes from Sears and other companies. So the next time a rag tag team of researchers armed with cameras, laptops, and an old Sears catalog knocks in your door and asks if they can take a quick tour
前门，他手里拿着一根棒球棍。如果我们上车，我们就跑。除了偶尔的失误，罗斯和丽贝卡认为，他们和其他寻房者已经帮助识别了来自西尔斯和其他公司的近50000栋套件房屋。所以，下次当一队拿着相机、笔记本电脑和旧西尔斯目录的杂牌研究人员敲你的门，问他们是否可以快速参观一下
of your basement, don't be frightened. They're there to help. And who knows, you might even be standing in an undiscovered model. Have you ever seen a seer's schoolhouse? Because I saw that they offered that one year. Oh, yeah, I've been looking for that a long time. Good Lord. I've been hunting that thing down like it's my job. CIRIS HOMES ON THE ONLY CIRIS ARCHITECTOR DAUDING THE LANSCAPE.
你的地下室时，不要害怕。他们是来帮忙的。谁知道呢，你甚至可能正站在一个未被发现的型号里。你见过西尔斯的校舍吗？因为我看到他们有一年提供了那个。哦，是的，我找那个找了很久了。天哪。我一直在追寻那个东西，就像它是我的工作一样。西尔斯的房子不是景观中唯一的西尔斯建筑。
Carton I talk about the adaptive reuse of massive CIRIS buildings all across the US. After this. The New York Times Years before Kurt Colstad joined the team at 99% in visible, he and I started corresponding by email. Among other things, he sometimes sent over story ideas. And one of those was about an old Sears building he moved into in Minneapolis. It's not a Sears home, it's a Sears plant, a huge city block sized warehouse,
卡顿（Carton），我谈谈美国各地大型西尔斯建筑的适应性再利用。之后。《纽约时报》，在库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）加入99%隐形团队的前几年，我和他开始通过电子邮件通信。除其他事项外，他有时会发送故事创意。其中之一是关于他搬进明尼阿波利斯的一栋旧西尔斯建筑。那不是西尔斯的房子，那是西尔斯的工厂，一个巨大的城市街区大小的仓库、
distribution center, and retail store. Yeah, and when I was really young, I used to actually go shopping in this thing. It was this 12 story Art Deco Sears. I'd go there with my parents, but for most of my years in Minnesota, it was just an abandoned building. I used to have, like, for miles along this overgrown railroad
配送中心和零售店。是的，当我真的很小的时候，我实际上经常去这个地方购物。那是一栋12层的装饰艺术风格的西尔斯。我和父母一起去那里，但在我在明尼苏达州的那些年里，它只是一栋废弃的建筑。我曾经有，比如，沿着这条杂草丛生的铁轨走几英里
track that ran past the building in a trench. And at the time, that big complex was kind of this ominous presence that you just kind of slip past on your bike and, you know, not get too close to you. So you basically don't engage with it at all. It's not really something like you go up to, you just cycle past it quickly. Yeah. Yeah. It's just, you know, and it took a multiple city block. So it was really kind of, you know, between the parking lot and the building, it was just this big, empty presence in the city. And then suddenly, you know, I moved back
它在沟渠中经过这栋建筑。当时，那个庞大的建筑群是一种不祥的存在，你只是骑自行车滑过，你知道，不要靠得太近。所以你基本上根本不与它互动。这不是那种你会走过去的东西，你只是快速骑车经过它。是的。是的。它只是，你知道，它占据了多个城市街区。所以它真的有点，你知道，在停车场和建筑之间，它只是城市中一个巨大的、空洞的存在。然后突然，你知道，我几年后搬回了
to the Midwest years later, and this place is totally transformed. It had been renamed the Midtown Exchange, and it was full of all these little shops and eateries on the main floor, plus offices and apartments and condos above. And those old rail tracks that I'd biked along had been cleared and paved and turned into this five mile greenway,
中西部，这个地方完全变了。它被重新命名为中城交易所（Midtown Exchange），主楼层挤满了所有这些小商店和餐馆，加上上面的办公室、公寓和共管公寓。我曾经骑车经过的那些旧铁轨已经被清理、铺平，变成了这条五英里的绿道，
which was really neat, sort of this ready-made rails to trails conversion. Right. And I got really interested in this, not just as a building, but also as an urban phenomenon, right? Like how they'd turned this nothing into a something again. So I naturally, being an architecture geek, started digging into the history of Sears. So what did you find in your research? Well, for starters, Richard Warren's Sears himself was born in Minnesota, where he actually started something
这真的很棒，算是这种现成的“铁路转步道”（rails to trails）转换。对。我对这个非常感兴趣，不仅是作为一栋建筑，而且作为一种城市现象，对吧？就像他们如何把这个“无”再次变成“有”。所以，作为一个建筑极客，我自然开始挖掘西尔斯的历史。那么你在研究中发现了什么？嗯，首先，理查德·沃伦·西尔斯（Richard Warren Sears）本人出生在明尼苏达州，他在那里实际上开始了一些
watches in the late 1800s. Then over time, he moved operations to Chicago and started growing out this larger mail order business. And it basically became the Amazon of the early 20th century. And in the 1920s, they started branching out even more, adding retail outlets to their distribution centers, all the way from Boston to Seattle.
19世纪末的手表业务。然后随着时间的推移，他把业务搬到了芝加哥，并开始发展这个更大的邮购业务。它基本上成为了20世纪初的亚马逊。在20世纪20年代，他们开始更多地扩张，将零售店添加到他们的配送中心，从波士顿一直到西雅图。
And you've shown me pictures of these. They all look surprisingly similar, even though they're scattered across the entire US. They have some different brick styles, but they're all kind of boxy, they have big windows and other details in common, including these really great distinctive art deco style towers. Yeah, they look a little bit like castle towers or something. And they're a big giveaway if you're hunting these kinds of serious buildings. Totally. And they serve to function too. They basically concealed these huge water systems that then serve
你给我看了这些照片。它们看起来惊人地相似，尽管它们散布在美国各地。它们有一些不同的砖块风格，但它们都有点方方正正，它们有大窗户和其他共同的细节，包括这些非常棒的、独特的装饰艺术风格的塔楼。是的，它们看起来有点像城堡塔楼之类的。如果你在寻找这类西尔斯建筑，它们是一个很大的线索。完全正确。它们也起到了功能作用。它们基本上隐藏了这些巨大的水系统，然后服务于
the floors below. Yeah, once you know the towers and these other details, you can really easily start to spot other towers in other cities. A lot of that commonality traces back to this one architect in particular, George Kohl Nimins. He did a lot of work for Sears. He even designed it one point, a mansion for the company's president, but he's mostly known for his big scale commercial work. And among other things, he worked on this really
下面的楼层。是的，一旦你知道了塔楼和这些其他细节，你就可以真正轻松地开始在其他城市发现其他塔楼。很多这种共同点可以追溯到这位特定的建筑师，乔治·科尔·尼明斯（George Kohl Nimins）。他为西尔斯做了很多工作。他甚至在某一点上为公司总裁设计了一座豪宅，但他主要以他的大型商业作品而闻名。除其他事项外，他参与了这个非常
big early plan, an administrative hub for Sears in Chicago. But this is not the Sears tower of Chicago or the now Willis town. It's something else. Right, right. That actually came many decades later, but amazingly, it was only half again as big as this really old complex, but nobody really knows about. The old complex was built a bit west of downtown, and it was about three million square feet. The company boasted that it was
大的早期计划，西尔斯在芝加哥的行政中心。但这并不是芝加哥的西尔斯大厦或现在的威利斯大厦（Willis Tower）。它是别的东西。对，对。那实际上是几十年后才出现的，但令人惊讶的是，它只有这个没人真正知道的旧建筑群的一半大。旧建筑群建在市中心以西一点，大约有300万平方英尺。该公司吹嘘它是
the largest commercial complex in the world at the time, and it spanned multiple blocks. It covered existing streets, so it actually blocked off city streets, and they had to get special permission, of course, from the city to do that. And the place basically functioned like a city within the city. It had its own power plant, it had its own corporate, you know, employee-based fire department. And it even had its own radio station, WLS, short for World's Largest Store. I love that it had its own commercial commercial radio station that's so great. Yeah, I mean they got sick of basically buying airtime on other radio stations.
当时世界上最大的商业综合体，它跨越了多个街区。它覆盖了现有的街道，所以它实际上阻断了城市街道，当然，他们必须获得城市的特别许可才能这样做。这个地方基本上像城中之城一样运作。它有自己的发电厂，它有自己的企业，你知道，基于员工的消防部门。它甚至有自己的广播电台，WLS，即“世界最大商店”（World's Largest Store）的缩写。我喜欢它有自己的商业广播电台，这太棒了。是的，我的意思是他们厌倦了基本上在其他广播电台上购买播出时间。
And eventually they were like, hey, you know what? We'll just start our own radio station. Of course. Because at the time, the series is this giant. It's America's biggest retailer and they just kept expanding too. They kept following kind of where the country took them. At first they did mail order where they served rural populations. Then they added these mixed-use plants with retail outlets to serve cities. And then as people moved out to the suburbs, you know,
最终他们就像，嘿，你知道吗？我们将开始我们自己的广播电台。当然。因为当时，西尔斯是这个巨人。它是美国最大的零售商，他们也一直在扩张。他们一直在跟随国家带他们去的地方。起初他们做邮购，服务于农村人口。然后他们增加了这些混合用途的工厂和零售店来服务城市。然后随着人们搬到郊区，你知道，
they began to go into these shopping centers. Today, obviously, Sears is not doing quite as well. And a lot of that complex in Chicago, for example, has been torn down. But some parts are still around. And some of you haven't been reused, including that central iconic tower. Because it's really hard to reuse a million plus square feet inside of a city. Yeah, it's incredibly difficult. And almost impossible to find a single corporate client who could take that on. And so like the one in Minneapolis, for instance, it had to bring in all these different stakeholders, you know, a local hospital and get the city on board and other developers so that, you know,
他们开始进入这些购物中心。今天，显然，西尔斯的表现并不太好。例如，芝加哥的那个建筑群大部分已经被拆除了。但有些部分仍然存在。有些你还没有被重新利用，包括那个中央标志性的塔楼。因为在城市内部重新利用一百多万平方英尺真的很难。是的，这极其困难。而且几乎不可能找到一个单一的企业客户能承担这个任务。所以就像明尼阿波利斯的那个例子，它必须引入所有这些不同的利益相关者，你知道，一家当地医院，让城市加入，以及其他开发商，这样，你知道，
there was a plan to make it mixed use from the start. But these buildings also have some advantages too for adaptive reuse, you know, they're built of sturdy concrete and masonry and they get a lot of light on all sides because they have these huge windows. And so when you wrote me years and years and years ago, it was in part a story about how cities are reusing these serious buildings. Yeah, and that's what really fascinating to be the most.
从一开始就有一个混合用途的计划。但这些建筑在适应性再利用方面也有一些优势，你知道，它们是用坚固的混凝土和砖石建造的，而且因为它们有这些巨大的窗户，它们在各个方向都能获得充足的光线。所以当你多年前写信给我时，这在某种程度上是一个关于城市如何重新利用这些西尔斯建筑的故事。是的，这对我来说是最迷人的地方。
It's not just that they're being reused, but it's the stories that they tell about the different cities they're being reused in. So in some ways, it's like this big urban experiment. You know, if you put these different boxes that all look kind of the same and are all, you know, sort of similar in size and you spread them out across the country and you abandon them, you know, what happened? And it turns out that you get these very city-specific stories of abandonment and reuse that tell you something about these different places. Yeah. Okay, so what are some of your favorites?
这不仅仅是重复利用的问题，更在于它们在不同城市被重复利用时所讲述的故事。在某种程度上，这就像是一个巨大的城市实验。你知道，如果你把这些看起来大同小异、尺寸也差不多的盒子分散到全国各地，然后又废弃它们，会发生什么呢？结果发现，你会得到关于废弃和再利用的、非常具有城市特色的故事，这些故事能让你了解这些不同的地方。是的。好的，那么你最喜欢其中的哪些呢？
What did you discover? Well, in Seattle, famous for its coffee, there's an old plant south of downtown that's been transformed into the headquarters of Starbucks. And the Los Angeles plant is being renovated right now, but for a long time, it was basically down to just the retail store on the ground floor and the rest of the building was empty. But of course, even an empty building when you're talking about Hollywood has a function. You can rent it out for filming.
你发现了什么？嗯，在以咖啡闻名的西雅图，市中心南边有一家旧工厂被改造成了星巴克的总部。洛杉矶的那家工厂目前正在翻新，但很长一段时间里，它基本上只剩下底层的零售店，其余部分都是空的。当然，即使是一栋空楼，在好莱坞也有它的功能。你可以把它租出去拍电影。
So it became a filming location. And then a lot of cities sort of followed the Minneapolis example. And Boston was the first one to do it where they just said, you know, we have to bring in a bunch of different programs to make this work for our city. So they, you know, had theaters and sports complexes and daycare centers and Memphis and Minneapolis and other cities follow it's suit. And so there's a little serious building in Uptown, Oakland, what we call Uptown, is if you drive up telegraph or away from beautiful downtown Oakland, California. It's a beautiful uptown. We'll go in California.
所以它成了一个拍摄场地。后来很多城市都效仿了明尼阿波利斯的做法。波士顿是第一个这样做的城市，他们说，我们必须引入各种不同的项目才能让它为我们的城市所用。于是他们有了剧院、体育中心和托儿所，孟菲斯、明尼阿波利斯和其他城市也纷纷效仿。在奥克兰的上城区有一栋小西尔斯大楼，我们称之为上城区，如果你沿着电报大道离开美丽的加州奥克兰市中心往上走，那是一个美丽的上城区。我们去加州吧。
You'll see a little one and what did they use that one for? So that place is really small and it's called the telegraph lofts and basically they're live work units. So they're residential units and there's some self-storage and other stuff, but mainly it's residential. Right, which is probably the thing we need the most in the Bay Area. Oh yeah, yeah, if there are empty buildings to be reused here,
你会看到一个小一点的，他们把它用作什么了？那个地方真的很小，叫电报阁楼，基本上是居住工作两用单元。所以它们是住宅单元，还有一些自助仓储之类的东西，但主要是住宅。没错，这可能是湾区最需要的东西。哦，是的，如果这里有空楼可以再利用的话，
I would hope we could just turn them all into more housing. Amen. All right. Thanks, Kurt. Yeah. 99% invisible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Sheree Fusef, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer.
我希望我们能把它们全部变成更多的住房。阿门。好的。谢谢你，库尔特。是的。《99%隐形》本周由乔·罗森伯格制作，技术制作由谢丽·福塞夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人。
Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Truffleman, Vivian Lee, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to the rig's family and the other Sears homeowners of Illinois. And to Matt Billmire for driving our producer Joe Rosenberg the entire length of Illinois. Twice. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row and Beautiful,
库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、薇薇安·李、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢里格斯一家和伊利诺伊州的其他西尔斯房主。还要感谢马特·比尔迈尔开车带着我们的制作人乔·罗森伯格跑遍了整个伊利诺伊州。两次。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，制作于美丽的广播街，
Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have lots of pictures of old Sears
加州奥克兰市中心。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们的网站上有大量旧西尔斯
catalogs and the adaptive reuse of Sears buildings on our website. It's 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目录和西尔斯大楼适应性再利用的照片。网址是99PI.org。Radiotopia。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。